hey what's up Daniel Dwyer here Chris
waters hello it's time to unbox a box
thing where's your space mode we got a
new but I don't have a space month but I
do have this space video game console
it's the destiny ps4 bundle comin at you
like Cleopatra four hundred and fifty
dollars it's time to open it oh you came
prepared
what do you think I come unprepared
unboxing you got it's not the one
without a space mug Danny you're gonna
chip me I don't know it depends on how
it goes
spin around teamwork baby oh right make
it a dream working you wanna you wanna
gonna unsheath ish do it take this
tumbler comfortable oh yeah oh let's
come out today oh it's a beautiful
PlayStation in a minute there's more
stuff to cut I'll cut down hold on a sec
okay it's a box with an AA doctor's feel
I can't wait for the next box inside of
this box there we go
you got this sweet other box you can
just have if you want put it in your hat
in your room look at it mad boxes you
got boxes on boxes alright let's get
let's get into here I like this uh art
yeah what do we got we got our tight art
Hunter with the hood warlock Titan
that's my guest space magic space magic
put this over see what's on the other
side oh it's a picture of taste of
things to come of old glacier white
PlayStation 4 we do a you saying later
or lasya lesson we say Gillogly glossy a
glossy hey ah
first things first a main event let's
get this guy yeah well I like how it
looks a little boom boom boom how's it
feel
I've already smudged it with my thumb it
actually came pre smudged
oh really unfortunately lets get that
yeah let's get that thanks Kaz Hirai
Nance it's no problem little Windex
they'll do me no problem ah so yeah this
is sorry and if I'm gonna you moving it
around to the glacier white add this
sis's angles here it's got lights up
blue as well when you got it on that's
neat
this is it itched here on the
on the PSN on ps4 anyways it looks a
little more pronounced because you can
get some shadows in there it's also know
it looks really slick it's it's I like
this it feels less dust the dust will
appear less obvious I know for sure my
favourite bit is this though check that
bad boy yeah look at that
okay yeah you digging it you know where
those buttons are 2-tone because
obviously the other ones got you know
back on black basically it's a mystery
where those things you don't know where
they use them all the time like how much
that PlayStation button just pops off
but I am look like I turn it to its
Wonder and where's my white ps4 why
isn't it turning on yet it's calling out
in the darkness for its mate that's
right
this is really cool I like that look now
the next question is do you guess
give me the stand give me some stand
action knocking stuff over in my say
Stan there is a standard picture it on
the front of the box feel it ministry
misunderstand alright any case sons
well it's like your basic basic cable
situation what's that there oh yeah this
we have here is the destiny get game box
I guess you would call it
sadly all of this is a regular
regulation or live stuff god oh you got
your you got your headset what do you
want Weiss you want a white HDMI I'm
sure yes I want them all to be white God
want it all to be speche you know I've
got them how much does it cost ready to
paint a HDMI cable even the booklets and
it's night still blue got down with
grave disappointment on the part of
Daniel are uh not for resale this does
come with some of the bonuses that you
get for buying the sort of PlayStation 2
version it's one of them a multiplayer
map specifically us as dust palace
strike force map I think it's or strike
map I think it says it on the back there
as well yes a new sub list of weapons
ships and gear get you good gear yeah uh
there it is exclusive uh yeah to see
it's picking the standard pictured man
I'm telling you look at that boss
advertising right I gotta make sure I'm
gonna make sure tear it apart there
or no it's not in there took that one in
the grill your doobie road oh man it's
just Stan sold separately like literally
where I was pointing just a second ago
definitely Fairplay $450 not bad let me
clear up the shot here for 50 bucks
hmm save a couple bucks off the old
destiny
yeah 30-day trial never should have
PlayStation Plus if you don't on ps4 and
you wanna play destiny I'll be a good
chat if you don't want to play destiny
or you're already for ps4 maybe not of
course they what they do you know they
have the 30 day trial membership but
they're getting you for that PS Plus
afterwards what can you in that's that's
the world we live in folks
voila
is it the end yet I think we're done